ce que car observe en Ukraine depuis
depuis le début de son intervention
c'est que les Russes et les forces
armées russes ont mis en place une
stratégie de stockage de composants
électroniques entre 2014 et 2022 cette
constitution de stock a permis à l'armée
russe et l'État russe de se prémunir
temporairement de l'effet des
sanctions de 2022 de l'intervention
russe jusqu'à mi-223 on observait une
consommation des stocks préexistants
comment est-ce qu'on observait cela dans
tous les sy de rus des systèmes d'armes
ruses que l'on documentait en Ukraine
que ce soit des drones des missiles des
systèmes de télécommunication et cetera
lorsque les nous les disséquions nous
regardions les numéros de série les
chaînes d'approvisionnement de ces
composants électroniques ceci avait été
acquis avant l'intervention russe depuis
mi-223 les composants que nous
documentons dans les systèmes d'armes
russes ont été fabriqués après 2022
après l'invasion russe et donc après la
mise en œuvre des sanctions vous avez là
sur la photo le l'exemple d'un d'une
munition reuse land 7 russe dans
laquelle en mars dernier mars 2023 nous
avons documenté pour la première fois
des composants fabriqués après
2022 comme je le disais cette stratégie
de stockage elle a permis aux forces
armées russes de de une certaine le leur
donner une certaine résilience
temporaire face à ces sanctions puisque
elle pouvait utiliser librement ces
stocks là sans avoir à
s'approvisionner en s'approvisionner
mais aussi elle a permis à la Russie de
défendre un narratif très
utile quant à la question de
l'inefficacité des sanctions et vous
aviez que ce soit en Russie pour les
citoyens russes ou à l'extérieur tout un
narratif sur la question de cette
inefficacité et des sanctions de dire
mais si les russes continuent à pouvoir
produire de l'armement c'est que ce que
nous imposons à nos entreprises et à nos
citoyens n'est pas efficace et il faut
donc penser à autre chose